10,000 men in our town one single
mustache and it has to be on my dad it
makes my stomach hurt
what kind of mustache
a big one all right let's begin with
this talk with a mustache a big one
we're gonna draw this mustache with pure
CSS today are you guys with me so in
regard to CSS everything has to be in
this box model so in CSS world you
cannot really sink outside of a box
because literally everything has to be
in a box that's why not many people are
as enthusiastic as I am about drawing
stuff with pure CSS but today I'm
telling you that we are going to work
inside of the box and somehow transform
a single div element into this mustache
shape I want you give a few points out
as the common knowledge qualms before we
dive into live coding and I'm pretty
sure you guys are all very savvy about
CSS so just bear me with me for a second
the first thing I wanna point out is one
single death comes with three visual
elements in case three boxes for us to
manipulate with the help of pseudo
elements before and after second is that
shadow could be of any color and
multiple shadows can be casted by one
single object like so you have i we have
many many shadows or in different color
here and try to draw this keyboard
colorful keyboard and certain things but
polar radius can be defined individually
for each corner and all be different for
each corner and first thing is borders
are not always a rectangle shape its
shape changes according to the adjacent
border setting and the polar radius
setting of the two corners like for
example you see the up we don't have
polar radius but down we have polar
radius and you have a very curious shape
of a border which you can manipulate and
get interesting results
so let's now dive into live coding as I
said before the four that came out was
just gonna have one single death and I'm
gonna add a class name to it
mustache and we're done with HTML for
for the for the rest of this coding
session and then we can close it for now
and now with with a style sheet
first thing we're gonna try to do is to
draw two circles and circles are fairly
easy to draw we just have a rectangle
and I had border radius 50 50 % to it so
let's let's begin how about width to 180
pixel and height to 180 peak so I made
the merriment sturdy and I'm slardar for
this presentation so that it's easier to
see and then we have border radius 50 50
% and I'm also gonna have
position:absolute because we won't have
easy control of each elements placement
and doesn't interfere with other animals
placement and the position:absolute is
good for this purpose and then I'm gonna
define a color to be black and we're
gonna refer to this color with a CSS
trick called current color the dependent
for doing so and let me show you how to
do that background color will just say
current color and we're gonna keep doing
this because the benefit is that you
want to change the color of the whole
icon we can only change your ones here
for the color and the area where else is
referring to this color so we don't
change like in multiple places
so now let's refresh now we have a
circle but the ulema shine we need two
circles and like i said we only have
three elements to manipulate with so i
don't want to use another pseudo
elements it have to be reserved for
other parts so how do you make another
circle without using a pseudo elements
I'm gonna use Spock shadow since we
already have a circle and the shadow of
a circle will also be a circle and you
can have any as many shadows as you want
so we're just gonna have to Bach shadows
here we go the first one first value is
X offset and Y offset 240 pixel and
spread to be 0 and blur to be 0 because
we want them to be the exact same size
and sharp edges so no blurriness and the
color I will send set it to current
color
and then we're going to continue to have
another box shadow sir second one the X
offset is 300 pixel and 240 pixel X Y
offset zero speck spread and zero blur
current color I hope it doesn't do that
every single time now we have two
circles just with one single element now
we actually don't need the main object
to show up we just need their shadows
it's kind of creepy huh
it's like horror movie just see the
shadow of the murderer but you don't see
the murderer so we're gonna remove you
know you know we don't need you guys go
away so we now have like a just two
circle next thing is the main part
that's we're gonna draw the the curved
shape shape off of the of the mustache
but how do we do that everything has to
start with a box so let's just start
with the box using before pseudo
elements and give it a width and height
and as you roll oh I forgot we need you
to set the content to be a empty screen
for a pseudo element you show up and as
you roll we're gonna have position set
you absolute so that we can control them
very easily and here I'm gonna try to
draw this curve part with border button
so I'm just gonna add a border button to
be solid and 180 pixel sickness and
current color as a color as well to make
it easier for you guys you see I'm also
going to make the the box the main box
show up by adding a temporary red
background color we're gonna remove them
eventually
so now I just you recap the red part is
the main box and the black part is a
folder button and what we want to is to
somehow curve curve the the black part
up so that it becomes like the left part
of the mustache how do we do that we're
going to use a polar radius set to just
one corner remember what can only set we
can set any corner to any value so we're
gonna only set you the bottom left
corner so let's just get some value and
see what happens
border-radius it's going clockwise so
the first one thought body is top left
top right bottom right and button left
so we want to set the the fourth value
to be let's just try something like a
hundred pixel and see what happens so
it's now curved up but we should go
further the height of the black part is
180 pixel as we said it so it can at
least go to 180 s so let's try that and
see what happens
refresh so now the curve is go all the
way up to the top edge of the black part
but it didn't go beyond what we want it
actually go beyond and curve the whole
thing up maybe talk to the top edge of
the red rectangle that's what we want so
let's just go extreme and set it to 100%
awesome so that's that's what we need
we're already getting very close and we
don't need the red part let's just get
rid of that and next things we are gonna
try to remove this part on top of the
left circle I'm just exactly on top of
it so we just add a little left value to
be 30 top to be 120 so here we go now
what's left is just to rotate them let's
see if it is thatthat simple so let's
just rotate them add a little transform
rotate and negative 40 degree and see
refresh
didn't go as planned because the rotate
center
was not the center that we wanted
whatever one is that it it rotate center
around the center of the circle but it's
not right now it's not that so we just
need to set transform origin to to the
right side and to the top should be 210
pixel and let's see if that works now as
per its kind of perfect you just rotate
or like around the circle and we can try
it by like changing the value up and
down and see like what happens 40 you
just go around like this it's really
good because the later I want to animate
them and we want them to do in this
behavior rotate really like this not
like a crazy person or it's crazy
mustache so now we just we have most of
them already we just need to mirror the
piff before and then copy paste them for
the after and change everything just to
be the other way so it's just copy and
paste and change before to after and one
thing we need to change the polar radius
it's not applied to the button left it
should be button right so it's gonna
change the third value which 100% and
force back to zero and a scene let's do
that one that one so now nice is it's
right but the rotate is to the other way
it should be positive 40 degrees in some
negative and the transform origin also
needs to be on the left side so you'll
change the left changing your right to
the left and then like we have in it
there and we just need to move to the
right so we're just gonna change the
left value to 330 and before I do that I
want to move them hello to the centers
I'm just gonna add a little left to the
main object so like when i refresh is in
a good place
well we have a mustache now is that fun
we only take what seven minutes to do to
do that and I hope everyone
thank you so I hope everyone's sort of
pick up pick up a little tricks and you
show your friends after the conference
so this is me I introduce I am I love a
lot of things I love humour I loved
hip-hop fel of icons I'm a huge type
nerd but I also like procrastination
procrastination is padding something
that it's watering a plant it's doodling
procrastination is trying to grow a
mustache but obviously I cannot grow a
mustache so he said I draw a mustache
out of pure CSS and I was so fascinating
I didn't just draw one I draw 512 icons
with just pure CSS since I'm a master
procrastinators over the years and my
CSIs was about procrastination I have
known something about proximation and
sometimes what I need to do is to tell
myself if something this is a trick
remember if something takes less than
ten minutes to do just do it right away
so you stop procrastinating I'm like I
can take out the trash under take ten
minutes I can call my dentist or or I
can learn some CSS that's what I find
this mature that I made is perfect for
this beginner to learn some CSS trick
within a really short time frame and has
the contents is condensed and also there
is immediate satisfaction and that's
what's important in self learning to
keep you motivated so I spent a lot of
time making a website a web app to host
all 512 icons in a web app and sort of
made it in a way that it is helpful for
other people to learn from it and I'll
show you how it works so this is an app
you can click on any icon to activate a
right panel the Internet didn't work
oh it works so you can activate a right
panel we will show you the HTML code and
the CSS code you can copy them by click
on this button and what score is that a
lot of people didn't find the logo type
are also just pure CSS and you can click
on them and you can see how to draw ass
out of CSS with one single div and also
you can hover you can mouse over the
code block and see which part of the
code is drawing which part of the icon
so that you can sort of like diving and
see how this saying crazy scene works or
not so crazy to those static people and
then you can if you are want to learn
more it's very important for you to get
your hands dirty so you can try it on on
code pen so we click on cocaine which is
migrate all the color code pen and can
start like changing values or it made it
made it into a new icon and one of the
benefit of having your icon in CSS is
that you can't animate them that's the
main reason I started doing this because
I saw very cool
I can omission over over other people's
website so I want you touch that as well
I'm I start building but haven't
finished this animation playground for
this is an icon you can hover over the
animate also pure CSS of course and you
can sort you can pick any two icons and
icon a and I can't be and then you can
play the animation any animation it's
very crude because this is the default
animation but but that's a good start
you can start from here and add some
custom made keyframe animation and make
them really really really amazing and go
back and forth and also continue on code
pen to show you what kind of animation I
want people eventually be able to use
this future version of this animation
playground to make I did I I I create a
little code snippet for our mustache
icon let's review that it's very simple
just have crank it up a little bit very
simple just shake left shake right
and then it's applied to the before and
after pseudo elements is gonna shake it
so let's just copy the code to what we
were working on before and see if it
works now we have like a crazy talking
mustache the animation
I love animation animation credit goes
to me and my mood town by Tory Cove and
procrastination by John Kelly and the
the typeface credit goes to acumen Pro
wide by Robert slim patch and in the
right side is the model space Conan - I
use in all my code example and my code
editor is a typeface I'm working on
cosiest monel I have designed our
features to make it specifically to
typeset CSS code in your code editor you
can check it out
um CSS - Molo da20 nacio
it will be free to download when it's
ready and you can follow me on twitter
design jokes and thank you so much
[Applause]